- So, look, I picked this
route off against the Rams.
- This is what you were made for, man.
This is your route.
- [Josh Johnson:] There it go.
- Hey! Show them how to
do it, Marcus Peters!
[♪♪♪]
Lefkoe here, and it is "Underrated" time,
where we take damn good NFL
players and show you areas
where they're surprisingly great.
Kinda like the surprisingly
great rates of State Farm?
Yeah, you betcha.
Today, we're focusing on my main man,
Marcus Peters of the Baltimore Ravens,
who, I think has always been underrated.
I'm the plug. I'm getting
Madden on the phone.
It's time to get those ratings up.
Yo, Jake, call Madden.
Let's figure this out.
- [Jake:] Calling Madden ratings adjuster.
- [Lefkoe:] Well, look who it is.
Clint Oldenburg. How you doin', Clint?
- Hey, I'm good.
Good to see you again.
- Marcus Peters. This guy,
he jumps routes, he covers,
but I got two interesting categories, OK?
- OK.
- All right, let's call him up.
My favorite corner in the NFL.
Jake, call my guy Marcus Peters.
- [Jake:] Calling Marcus Peters.
- [Lefkoe:] And there he is.
The big baller, shot-caller.
Nobody better, Marcus Peters.
Marcus, this is Clint. He is
the Madden ratings adjuster.
Say what's up.
- Sup wit it, man? That's
why you so cool, dawg.
[Clint laughing]
- Listen, I already
spoke to the folks at EA,
and if we can impress Clint
with your catching ability,
they're going to consider
bumping you up to possibly the
No. 1 catch-rated corner in the game.
- For sure. Hey, man,
I appreciate that too.
- Clint, are there certain
drills that you think
would be great for corners to test catch?
- We'd really wanna see is more, like,
wide receiver-type drills, like catch difficulty.
Can he not see the ball all the way?
Can he react to it very quickly?
Just some of those ball skills
you don't see very often from
DBs.
- OK, OK, OK.
We gon' do something.
- There's another rating
I wanna tackle first.
Take a look at kick
accuracy. It is so low.
Clint, how can I test this?
- Wow. Uh, all right.
That's an interesting one. We
don't get this one very often,
but I guess if you can
test him in placement,
check his accuracy on punting,
might be some room for improvement.
- I do this. We talking
'bout the Dustin Colquitt's
dropping it in the corner
type of punting, you feel me?
[Clint laughing]
- OK. Well, if you're feeling confident,
let's put you to the test, man.
- Let's do it.
- All right. We'll be waiting.
- OK. Clint, I appreciate you.
All right. So check this out.
We're gonna go after your kick accuracy rating with a
coffin corner punt challenge.
If you've noticed, Marcus,
we placed three semicircles
just in front of the end zone.
You hit the smallest innermost circle,
that's worth five points.
The middle is three.
The large outer one is worth two.
You're gonna get five
attempts, and every punt,
your total goes up by that amount.
And as long as you're within 10 yards
of that outermost circle,
your rating stays the same.
We can improve your kick accuracy rating
by [fanfare Sound] 25 points today
if all five hit within
that inner semicircle.
- Oh yeah, that's easy
money. That's easy money.
I'm tellin' you, Dustin
Colquitt can vouch for me.
I do this.
- Well. All right, let's go.
- Ah, let's go, what have we got.
- [Lefkoe:] Wasting no time.
- I got some points. That's two.
So we got probably about a three.
- My man lookin' like
Marcus Colquitt out here.
- I love Dustin Colquitt, but if anything,
I'm gonna be his daddy.
[Marcus laughing]
Oh, shank. Shank!
- Mr. Peters,
that is not a good look
for the folks over at EA.
What do you think they're gonna give you
for that one, man?
- The motherf--ker, the
10 points. Whatever.
- Well, let's pick up the
spare on this next one.
Wow.
- It's too bad we're
not testing hang time.
- [Marcus:] Just a little bit inside.
- That looked pretty, though.
- Yeah. Last one.
I'mma get it in the yellow for sure.
Ooh. Bad snap.
Oh.
It's way far away. But we ain't-
hold on. We at the 5, though.
- [Lefkoe:] Yeah. It's at the 5.
- I'll take all the points, though.
- Well, listen, man.
The good news is your kick
accuracy rating is already so
low that, to be honest,
man, you can only go up.
- You feel me?
- Yeah, man.
I'm feeling good about
your chances right now.
- The best thing, though,
where I'm good at, though,
is the next one, I think.
And that's catching. So that's easy.
- My only question is,
is there anybody there that
can throw a football for us?
- Yeah, yeah. Hell yeah, for sure.
I got Cuz.
- Wait, who's Cuz?
Oh, that's my big cousin
Josh Johnson, man.
You know, played for all
32 teams in the league.
- Still going, too.
- Josh, what kinda hands does Marcus have
in terms of corners?
- I wouldn't compare him to
corners cuz they can't catch.
He got receiver hands.
- Hell yeah.
- Now Marcus, speaking of hands,
you have to see how your Madden
character fares with a few
passes. And I gotta admit,
they got you messed up, bro.
- [Josh:] Yeah, that's disrespectful.
- And the receiver still catches it.
That does not happen in real
life. Let's add a DB backpedal.
I want you to break on the ball.
Cuz I'm thinking if we show
Madden about your catching
skills doing this, it
won't even be a question.
- Fa sho. Let's do it.
- There is pressure, and I love it.
- [Marcus:] Oh!
- Oh man, what happened there?
- It was a bad jump timing by me.
- Timing is everything.
All right, what's on deck?
- We're gonna go dig.
- See, this is what Marcus
does. Breaking on balls.
This is his specialty, making that jump.
All right, Marcus.
We gotta wake it up for this last one.
What do you got for me?
- So, look.
- [Josh:] When you do that?
- I picked this route
off against the Rams.
So all I'm gonna do is just
get my ass to the sideline
and play it in and then high-point.
- This is what you were made
for, man. This is your route.
- [Josh:] There it go.
- Hey! Show them how to
do it, Marcus Peters!
[Marcus laughing]
- I don't know about you,
but I feel really good about today.
So I'm gonna be the plug.
I'm gonna take this tape to the adjuster,
but I want you on that call with me, OK?
So pick up when I hit
you up later, all right?
- For sure. but, yeah, man,
thank you for everything, bro.
Like I say,
I'm a fan of Madden, and
I'm not gonna complain about
nothing that, you feel
me, that I haven't earned.
So it's all good.
- My man Marcus talks the
talk. He walks the walk.
Clint, what did you think of the video?
- Great video. First of all,
kudos to you and your team. Very creative,
bringing back some
old-school Madden mechanics.
Showed some serious skills, even some
we didn't even know he had.
- All right, we're
getting him on the call,
cuz I need you to give
the ratings to his face,
so let's call Marcus.
- Hey, what's goin'
on with y'all, man?
How y'all doin', big dawg?
- Marcus!
- Clint, what's poppin', man?
Hopefully you been doin'
a good job over there
adjusting my shit.
- Hey, Marcus. Good to
talk to you man, thanks.
- All right, give us the goods.
Let's start off with punting first.
- There's bonus ratings
here, so we're gonna start
with kick accuracy.
Currently Marcus is a 14.
We're actually gonna bump
him up 13 points to a 27.
That makes him the ninth-
best corner in the NFL in kick accuracy.
Now, that doesn't stop there.
I also saw some kick
power. He was booming.
Moving up from a 15 rating
to 27, plus 12 points.
Now the 18th-best
cornerback in kick power.
[Marcus laughing]
- All right.
- Now catching is the big one.
Cuz I know that Marcus was already,
we were battling for that
No. 1 spot for catching.
- Yeah, Marcus was already
tied at No. 1 among corners
with a catch rating of 81.
He was tied with Richard
Sherman and Patrick Peterson.
He is gonna go up one point to an 82
and now is the highest-rated
catching cornerback in Madden.
[Marcus laughing]
- Ohhh! That leads us
to one question, Clint,
and I need an answer with
Marcus Peters on the line.
Is Marcus Peters underrated?
- Yes. Marcus Peters
is underrated.
- Dang!
- Appreciate it.
I salute everybody who out
there doing their thing
on the defensive back
end, but you feel me?
Hey, man, keep up, man. Your
boy out here setting a pace
that y'all ain't really fuckin' with.
- I love it. I love the honesty.
I love that Clint said on
tape that Marcus Peters
is underrated, and I love
that Marcus now
has the best hands for
any corner in the NFL.
That is "Underrated." I am Adam Lefkoe.
Big shoutout to the big dude
Marcus Peters for making it
happen, and a shoutout to State
Farm for their surprisingly
great rates for making
this episode possible.
Thank you for watching.
♪♪♪